okay hi everyone
back for another episode of science and
technology q a for kids
and others and we have a variety of
questions left over from last week which
i thought i would start with
so let's see we have one from parmenides
here
who are your favorite science fiction
authors what are your favorite
stories and movies you know i am a
terrible reader of fiction i it's one of
those things where i
keep on saying uh later in life i'll
read fiction
but i never get around to it i did read
some science fiction when i was a kid
and i was not wasn't always so thrilled
with it because i was always interested
in
you know what are the key ideas about
the world the future whatever
from the science fiction it's like give
me let me take this 50 page
uh story i just want to compress it to
the one page which is this is the idea
about the future
and i wasn't at that time so interested
in the kind of human
story i have to say that in more modern
times
the whole question about how humans
interact with technology in the future
and so on
i find much more interesting and i think
there's uh
there's a lot that can and should be
explored in science fiction
about the way that uh we think about
the human condition its relationship to
kind of our digital
the digital analog of humans our
relationship to ai
these kinds of things and i think
there's there's a lot that can be
explored where
where to write it as a as a as something
written as sort of philosophy
um would be much harder to understand
than writing it as something more like a
story
but having said that i can talk about a
few things that a few sort of science
fiction
kinds of things that i found uh
interesting
or whatever i think the first um
uh probably the first mostly movies
rather than books
um the first one that uh uh certainly
had an effect on me was 2001 a space
odyssey
which came out in 1968 um and actually
happened to be the the very first movie
that i saw in an actual movie theater
uh but um that's that's neither here nor
there
but um you know 2001
is interesting was interesting to me at
the time for its very sort of bright
vision of the future
and and really it was a mixture of a
story about space and a story about
computers
and i went back and looked at it uh back
a couple of years ago now
it's at its 50th anniversary to try and
sort of analyze
the movie and um uh what was in it
and what was significant about it i mean
i think that um
uh in a sense the um the human
characters in the movie
which i kind of respond to much more now
than i did when i was
eight years old or whatever um uh
are kind of interesting for being
uninteresting so to speak
uh the ai the computer the hell 9000
is um uh is in a sense one of the most
human characters in the in the whole
movie
but you know there were there were
themes in that movie that i thought were
interesting
about kind of the uh uh the the
the sort of large span of time from
sort of the earliest uh
interest in sort of science by kind of
the
the hominid pre-human ape-like creatures
at the beginning of the movie uh you
know flowing through to kind of the
the uh the future of the
extraterrestrials and so on
um at the end of the movie and i think
also uh
it was it was interesting to see you
know that was a place where
i could kind of see at least a vision
for what
uh computer technology the future might
look like it was interesting to look at
it 50 years later
and see what was gotten right what was
gotten wrong i mean there were a lot of
very interesting mistakes
like for example one of them is the idea
of of soft windows on the screen just
wasn't there
so for them different functionality was
a different physical screen
with different doing different kinds of
things the idea of
of sort of everything as software wasn't
really there um
and uh there were uh you know there
was a very um uh talk to your computer
type
type movie now you know in a sense some
of the things that i've done
in in developing software technology
have been things that have sort of
filled out
uh some of the things that were kind of
anticipated in a movie like that
about sort of be able to ask your
computer questions and have it give
meaningful answers
um things like this but um that was um
uh you know i think it's also kind of
charming in that movie
um there's uh you know you're talking to
the computer there's no
notion of of any kind of computational
language that the computer is using
or that anybody is using to sort of be
precise there's a certain amount of
of human precision language that sounds
like you know air traffic control
lingo um that's kind of the uh the
the taking natural language and making
it more precise just like a legal
contract would make things more precise
um but it didn't get to the point of
understanding that there will be sort of
a computational language
that would be a bridge between the human
and the computer and there are just a
few brief moments
where screens flash up essentially
computer code which is sort of a
charming mixture of mathematical
notation
and i think an early version of the pl1
computer language
that uh ibm developed ibm was sort of
the main consultant for that movie in
terms of
of computer technology but so that's
that's an example of a movie i i thought
was interesting i think
um oh gosh in more recent times there
just
there's there's lots of them i i i am uh
hasn't happened so much during this
pandemic but
um uh usually i kind of make a point of
i don't watch any television but i do
try and see a movie every week or two as
a way to sort of keep in touch with uh
what's happening in the world in general
um but other science fiction movies i
might mention
another one i i thought was um
uh was interesting was the contact
um maybe there's a theme here of of
extraterrestrial movies
um between 2001 which is ultimately an
extraterrestrial first contact movie
and uh contact which is an
extraterrestrial first contact movie
and movie i i helped with a bit arrival
which is another extraterrestrial first
contact movie
um i suppose uh uh
contact i thought was some
interesting movie i i you know it
portrays um
uh you know it was uh uh was
somewhat realistically portrayed version
of uh
kind of what it would be like
for uh humans to get an intelligible
signal
from extraterrestrials and what the kind
of human response to that would be
and um how one would kind of uh uh
understand what it was and a little bit
of the human story
behind sort of a discovery in in science
um i'm trying to think there are so many
other science fiction movies from the um
uh very um you know some sometimes
movies will have
a particular idea in them like you know
minority report which i'm not sure is a
particularly um uh uh
it wasn't particularly a movie that
especially resonated with me in in many
ways but
you know its whole sort of gesture based
interface was something that became a um
a very um uh notable feature of that
term of that movie
um it's always interesting when when um
uh
you know this was a question of of to
what extent are there really
sort of science technology etc ideas and
movies
to what extent are movies really human
stories and i think
to a large extent movies to be
successful have to be human stories if
they're movies about um
you know people like watching movies and
find interesting
movies which are ultimately about people
perhaps people
portrayed in a setting where they're you
know traveling on a spacecraft to
jupiter or something
uh rather than being in uh uh just
hanging out
um you know in in their uh you know
suburban setting or whatever
um but still it's it's got to be a story
about people
um and in a sense some of the stuff that
i find most intellectually interesting
is uh the places where sort of that
intersects with technology and
science and so on um and uh
uh the um uh so so sometimes those those
pieces are
very much kind of extracted from um from
the main part of the movie
um let's see i think um
uh if people want to ask about um
uh particular movies i could probably
give some more analysis but um
it's a that's at least a a rough thing
so let's see someone is asking here
crunchy is asking why do
people have emotions and feelings how do
emotions and feelings work like
happiness and anger and so on
there's an interesting question it's not
completely known
but in a sense emotions seem to be sort
of a
global setting about the brain like
a lot of what we do when we talk about
things when we think about very specific
things
they're very specific detailed uh
aspects
of uh of what we're thinking about you
know we might uh
and they and they involve very elaborate
probably very detailed patterns
of of activity in our brains patterns of
electrical activity in our brains when
we think about
some uh math problem or something we're
probably dealing with some very
elaborate pattern of uh
electrical firings in our brains that
represent those kinds of thoughts and so
on
when we're just like i'm happy i'm sad
whatever else that seems to be a much
more global thing in our brains
and i think the the general belief is
that
those more global things are associated
with sort of a a whole
wash of chemicals uh neurotransmitters
typically
through our brains rather than something
which is a more detailed pattern of
electrical activity
in some particular region of our brains
and i think that um uh
that's that's why kind of um various
kinds of drugs and things can have an
effect on sort of emotional state
uh probably more so than they than you
know you don't take
a um a drug that's specifically uh
lets you learn you know how to do
integrals in calculus or something
um it's uh so so they tend to
these things that have sort of a global
chemical effect on our brains
now you know to what extent how does
that actually work how does it translate
from the uh a neurotransmitter that
makes it more likely for certain
nerves to neurons to fire or whatever
else how does that translate
into a feeling of i'm happy i don't
think we really
know that the one thing that we we do
know
uh something that's been realized for
example charles darwin noticed this is
that
the expression of emotions between sort
of humans
and and animals is is somewhat similar i
mean even you know even the kind of the
the mouth you know the smile the growl
or whatever else
similar between you know humans and dogs
or whatever
um it's um uh and so
it seems like there's this kind of
global mechanism this sort of emotional
communication
emotional state that exists not just in
humans but also
across a wide range of of animals at
least in mammals
um and i think that uh that's
you know for example if we you know
there was a thing a long time ago i'm
really surprised that it hasn't been
more work done on this
of sort of the human dog communication
process
and you know what can your dog be saying
you know woof whatever else
um there's an extent to which one can
you know rather than the dog saying
you know i just figured out the solution
to this
equation which is very unlikely probably
for a dog to be saying
it's like i'm a happy dog i'm an unhappy
dog
i'm a hungry dog perhaps whatever else
and and these things are
are things where there's sort of more
global features
of the of the state of the brain of the
dog that
uh come out in uh in sort of
verbalizations
vocalizations that um uh one can more
readily translate
into something and by the way the
concept of i'm happy i'm sad whatever
else
seems to even transcend different
species um
and there's at least a certain extent to
which that's something where it's
probably the same neurotransmitter
that is uh that is representing these
kinds of things
now you know when we talk about
emotional states um
it's sort of interesting to to ask a
question
can we can we sort of define a space of
emotional states just like
we can say i don't know um
something that's that's often done these
days is um with computers
is so-called sentiment analysis so
you read a piece of text it's you know a
review of some product somewhere
and the question is is this a positive
review or is it a negative review
what is the sentiment of this review
does the person say this product is just
fantastic
this product is a piece of garbage you
know these are
you can you can rate those on different
sort of sentiment scales
and so there's a question uh just like
you can rate sort of the sentiment it's
it's kind of going from
happy with the product to sad with the
product or something it's kind of
defining an emotional
state with respect to let's say that
product
can you uh can you do the same kind of
thing can you define a kind of
a space of from from happy to sad
from from angry to to content from this
to that
and there are a variety of things over
the last probably 100 years and it was
particularly popular
oh probably in the early part of the
20th century
to try and make up these emotion spaces
which were kind of a representation
of these different sort of things where
you choose it's a it's
it's it's in one direction or it's
another direction you know where are you
in the sort of emotion space
and i think it's quite possible that the
people
found these sort of motion spaces that
have maybe
three four five parameters from uh you
know alert
to you know completely not paying
attention to this to that to the other
and i think there's at least a chance
that those different
parameters correspond very directly to
levels of different neurotransmitters in
our brains
and that that that really is a pretty
direct way
to understand you know how alert are we
how this are we
how how that are we so but i think it's
a it's
an interesting thing to the extent to
which for example
when we have verbal communication you
know we got words you say certain words
they have certain implied kind of
emotional
content you look at facial expressions
they have a certain implied emotional
content
same with with voice uh the quality
voice timbre things like that
have a certain implied emotional content
to what extent
can you roll back and say what is the
the underlying emotional thing that's
going on in the brain
and to what extent do you take the words
that are said
and then has sort of this overlay of
emotional state
you know some human languages have a
much more elaborately tonal and things
than for example english is
and i think you know that there's
there's a certain there's certain extra
levels of communication that one can
expect
which communicate various kinds of
things sometimes content there
but also potentially emotionally
emotional state
so that's a but i mean if you ask
the question you know the question was
asking why do people have emotions and
feelings
um uh you know that that's a there's
always a it's always a difficult
question in biology why
because you know the one thing we know
about biology is
if an organism is a particular species
of organism
dies out then we're not even talking
about that species
so the important thing in biology is for
species to keep going
and the fundamental way that any modern
species keeps going is sort of have more
children so to speak
um i say modern because back in you know
very early species didn't didn't really
have this notion of
of cycles of life and death and
generations and so on but but for the
last couple of billion years probably
maybe at least billion years
it's been sort of a story of you know
kind of
uh have more offspring um to to be a
successful species so to speak
so so often in biology there's some of
these questions about
uh how does some attribute of a
biological system
uh have a have an effect on uh
on improving your your propensity your
likelihood of having offspring
on improving your fitness to have
offspring and so on
and the sort of interest so it's often
interesting to go back and see
you know can you figure out what aspect
of this
thing that is a feature of biological
organisms
helps in you know why does it help in
having more offspring now sometimes
people get very confused because they
look for that
but it turns out that's not what's going
on it turns out that the feature of the
biological organism
is just a consequence of how the
organism grows or or some other
uh piece of of the development of the
organism that has nothing to do with
fitness it really
it's just a sort of side effect of of
the way that the organism has to sort of
grow it's
it's uh uh you know has to uh
grow out the the horn that's growing or
something it has to
it has to have this feature because
that's sort of just the way horns grow
so to speak um so i you know in terms of
emotions and so on
interesting question i don't i don't
immediately see
i'm not sure i can immediately describe
i mean there's probably things in um
you know it probably depends a bit on
on how the organism works with respect
to
uh you know is it is it a very um
herd-like organism or is it a loner type
organism
you know they're different uh um you
know things
you know hunt and packs or their lone
wolfs or whatever um i think those
wolves tend to be impacts which is why
you identify sort of the lone wolf idea
but there are other kinds of organisms
that
like cats for example that tend to be
very
uh you know one creature for itself so
to speak rather than we're just gonna
you know have a have a big pack um that
we're that we're existing in
i suspect that emotions have um uh
have a role in the way that kind of um
uh things work in packs i suspect also
they have a role
in the way that um uh yeah i mean
one very direct one will be uh for
mammals at least
we'll be sort of taking care of the
young so to speak and oh that's such a
cute
little creature you know let's take care
of it so to speak that's sort of an
important thing
for uh for the survival of the species
if you expect to have
uh you know if you expect to have
organisms which sort of
get born where sort of the baby phase
isn't very sophisticated and the baby
phase can't fend for itself
then you have to make sure that the
parents sort of take care of the
offspring
until it gets to the point where it can
uh sort of um
uh leave the nest so to speak and go off
and fend for itself
so anyway a few thoughts about um uh
origins of um emotions i i think
an interesting question i don't know the
answer to is how low
on the on the chain of life you see
emotional responses certainly see them
in mammals
um i don't know if you see them i'm
trying to think if you do you see them
in birds well you see birds
chirping chirping chirping happily um
whether they
uh whether one can identify clear
emotional responses that i do not know
i mean i i don't really i've never
really heard of anybody
talking about um a sad fish so to speak
that doesn't seem to be a thing
um you know that there are sort of other
attributes of organisms
that are sort of global brain attributes
like sleeping for example
which does happen in fish um but i don't
know of emotional states of of things
like fish
um so that's a good question i i'm not
sure
um there's a question here i noticed
just um
uh um
wow all kinds of comments here um
the uh there's a question from um
uh william in the space of all possible
mental states what is the ratio positive
versus negative states
is this a relative quantity is the
debate transformations
interesting question i mean i you know
look my personal observation about
us humans is that many of us get sort of
thrown a random thing which is our sort
of
average mental state you know i'm
and i'm happy about it so to speak i'm
generally a pretty
you know i'm in a pretty i'm a pretty
happy mental state kind of person
and and yet you know even when really
good things happen that's you know
it doesn't it's okay it's great but it
doesn't really make my mental state go
much
up when bad things happen no it's it's
bad it doesn't make my mental state go
much down
and you know i i i know plenty of people
just as a matter of human experience
where it's like they're sort of always
happy they're always sad
and they can be always sad even if
fantastically good things happen to them
they're still somehow always sad and
that that's i think it's
it's you know when perhaps when just uh
you know one gets used to a certain
mental state and maybe i don't know
whether my
you know maybe i've just chosen to call
the mental state that i have
a sort of a a generally happy mental
state and maybe to the outside it would
be
like oh that person is just grinding
tenaciously
on the work they're doing and they don't
seem happy at all but to me internally
at least it seems like it's like okay
great
you know things are good so to speak um
so i i think it's it's a little bit in
the
in the um uh maybe in the eye of the
beholder what counts as positive versus
negative
i think you know when when people do
experiments on rats and so on they often
try to assign mental states to rats oh
this rat
in this particular setting is you know
it's a depressed rat
um because why is it a depressed rat it
kind of hangs out in the corner of the
maze
and it refuses to do anything or it's a
very uh
you know very excited rat it's going to
explore the maze in
a in a very excited way i mean i i would
say that there probably are measurements
that can be made
for humans um that of sort of mental
states and i
you know i didn't mention this earlier
but but as we know more sort of personal
analytics data about ourselves
there are things that one can certainly
measure i mean we can certainly measure
not only the the sentiment of oh i'm
typing wonderful email
you know to talking about how terrific
the world is
or another thing is you know you look at
your sort of social network
and you're asking are you connecting out
to lots of people
now that's to some extent a am i an
extrovert am i an introvert
um or am i like i have been connected
out to a lot of people but i'm really
retracting and not talking to anybody
and that's kind of probably a sign that
that um your you know your sort of
mental state is
is going more to the in the negative
direction but um
you know and i i do tend to think that
in the in sort of assessing mental
states
and so on it's kind of like if if you're
uh trying to you know help somebody
understand their psychological state and
so on
it's um at least the way of the future
is okay
you know can you give me the last year
of social media communication
let's go analyze what what happened here
and you know do you
what can you tell from that about what's
going on but i don't think
um uh yeah somebody else commented here
that
people didn't have emotions then nothing
would ever get done that's
interesting that's that's that may very
well be true
if um uh you know i think there's a
there's a certain tendency and it's
identified not just
in in humans of you know are you
interested in going out and exploring
and going and you know uh and and
finding new things
or are you more like just i want to nest
and and
be sort of uh be comfortable so to speak
and i think those are
you know that's a that's one of these
sort of set points of for different
people and different times of life and
so on
that um uh that that were notices um but
i i think uh
um you know and sometimes there are i
mean it's always an interesting question
what what is the you know the motivation
that people have to do things
is is often very complicated to
understand it often has to do with their
own history
you know their interactions with other
people and so on and i suppose it's the
case
that in general terms if if nobody felt
anything
then quite possibly that there just
wouldn't they wouldn't feel motivation
either
and um uh and so as as uh as
uh cap was saying here um then nothing
would ever get done
the question here from dan do you think
the set of emotions is finite
that's a very interesting question is it
possible for evolution to bring a new
kind of emotion
or can we artificially create a new kind
of emotion i think it's a that's a very
interesting question
i think that insofar as it's true that
emotions
are associated with actual
neurotransmitters in our actual brains
we're probably stuck with what we have
um i mean
you could ask the question you know if
you have some some bizarre drug it's
probably not a not a great idea because
you know brains have been involved for a
long time
and throwing something some other random
thing in is probably a super bad idea
but um you could say you know can you
can you develop something which
is uh which would sort of affect our
brains in a way
that is very different from the way that
our existing neurotransmitters do it or
whatever else
um or is there a a sense in which
i mean you know the thing that always
strikes me uh
you know with respect to the human
condition and uh and things like
human emotions and so on you know you go
you watch
a play written by some ancient greek
playwright
and the things that are going on are at
a human level
so absolutely identical to the kinds of
things that go on today
it's clear that over the span of those
few thousand years
and all those changes in technology and
culture and so on
nothing has changed really in the core
of the human condition
and i think there's a there's a sort of
an interesting question
what can change in uh in sort of the
core of the human condition
and and in things like uh kind of the
possibility for different emotions i
mean like for example
let's imagine that we had a really close
link between our brains
and some digital device some very close
neural connection
where some digital device was reading
out lots of aspects of what we're
thinking in our brains
and feeding back you should do this you
should do that
i mean it's potentially a quite uh
you know it's a very difficult to parse
out
is this good is this bad is this
absolutely disastrous
um i mean there's certainly settings in
which that could be and
certainly science fiction has covered
some of these in which that notion of
the
sort of externally engineered uh kind of
way of getting people to think things is
absolutely disastrous
it's bad enough kind of uh uh sort of
persua trying to persuade people of
things
by education telling them the world
works this way the world works this way
the world works
this way it doesn't matter what you
think you're being told the world works
this way but if that's something that is
directly being inserted
directly into your thought process in
your brain that's
yet a different uh you know uh thing
that that has the potential for
for uh sort of bad ends to history so to
speak
but i think that the um uh you know the
sort of a question
of assume that you could sort of feed
into the brain
all sorts of things in response to
external stimuli could you do that in a
way that was
was very different from the way that
happens right now
and that we would read as sort of a
different emotion
uh interesting question i mean i tend to
think so here's a here's a way to think
about that perhaps
in our sort of higher cognitive
processes the main way we express those
is through language
you know people invent some new concept
you know the idea of a live stream or
something
and that becomes a word in our language
then we get to talk in terms of it
people get to you know build sort of a
stack of ideas about that
and so on um but as time goes on
language evolves and we end up with with
different
kinds of concepts different levels of
abstraction that we express in language
so far as i know that has not happened
with human emotions
so far as i know the um and maybe i'm
wrong but but um
so far as i know unlike language which
is this thing that is progressively
building
over the course of civilization human
emotions haven't worked that way
and and perhaps it's no surprise that
emotions are also things shared with
their animals
and uh which don't have the same kind of
ability
to don't appear to have the same kind of
ability to sort of build
with language progressively through
generations and sort of build up the
civilization of the cats or something
um and uh so so i think it's it's um it
is an interesting question whether there
is a
sort of language of emotions that can be
more more elaborate
than um uh but i think perhaps the other
point is
with language we get to communicate one
generation to the next we get to
communicate ideas
i'm not sure we do that really with
emotions i'm not sure that that's a
that's the same type of communication
that can happen um
in in that way um
anyway these are interesting questions
um
let's see there's a question here
um
it's a question here from jake uh
given that our brains are most likely
the source of everything yeah i think
that's a good
a good assumption is there a finite set
of combinations of matter in the brain
could there be a finite set of all
possible thoughts
yeah it's finite but it's really really
big
and and the thing to understand is about
sort of combinations of things it's like
how many possible passwords can you have
on your you know let's say you've got a
10 letter password
how many possible passwords can you have
it's a really lot
it's probably is it more than the number
of atoms in the universe
10 letters
can't work that out instantly have to
type it in to to know that but
it'll be comparable at least um and uh
i think that the um the thing to
understand is
that when you have even a fairly small
number of possible
uh of items each one of which can can
can work differently the total number of
combinations is very big it's just like
with music you know you're playing on a
piano maybe there are 88 notes
altogether
but maybe there are i don't know 20 25
30 notes that you
you would commonly use but the set of
possible musical pieces
is absolutely immense and um it's
it's so immense that you know in the
history of the universe
uh you know if if one have been playing
these pieces uh you know all the pieces
you know in the across the history of
the universe we wouldn't even be close
to having exhausted all of them so the
thing to understand is
when there are when there are when there
are lots of independent things that get
picked
uh the the total set of possibilities is
really huge
so when it comes to brains you know we
might have
on the order of 100 billion neurons in
our brains
maybe um uh maybe some number of
trillions of connections between neurons
and each one of those connections might
be in one of
thousands of states um and then if you
work out
sort of what does that mean what is the
total it's a thousand to the trillion
or something that's a incredibly huge
number
that's a number so big that in
certainly in the history of our universe
we're we're not even we're not even
close to beginning
to you know take a little bite out of of
all of those possibilities
so the fact that it is in principle
finite
is is not a a useful statement in terms
of saying
oh you could only think about these
number of things now now there's some
organisms that have many many fewer
neurons in their brains like for example
one organism studied a great deal as a
little critical the nematode the c
elegans and it has
about um altogether um it has
uh um uh let's see
1700 cells i think of which about a few
hundred are in its nervous system
so it has a you know a small number of
neurons
and um you can kind of see for all of
its neurons
you people know to some extent what does
that neuron do
by the way unlike us when when our
brains
form neurons go to
you know the ones that are going to make
our visual cortex go roughly at the back
of our heads the ones that are going to
make
different parts of our brain go roughly
to different places
but we're not we're not specifically
wired in a particular way
if you're a c elegans with only a few
hundred neurons then
you're wired in a very specific way like
this
particular neuron is connected to this
particular tentacle
and it does this particular thing this
particular neuron is connected to some
you know smell sensor and if it detects
this then it does that
it's much more of a a special purpose
piece of hardware than than our brains
are
um but uh you know you could ask a
question i mean for a creature like that
uh you know how many brain states does
it get into that's a much more finite
number and that's probably an answerable
thing um
you know by the time you're at an ant i
think an ant has 50 000 neurons if i
remember right
um and uh you know by the time you're
even an ant
you're just absurdly huge number of
possible combinations and so
the you know the the the can the the
thoughts of the ant
are already far greater than um uh then
you can sort of
expect to enumerate okay
let's see uh questions here well there's
a specific one from david
uh did i ever meet isaac asimov and or
arthur c clarke
unfortunately i neither i never met
either of those two
um i i knew uh uh isaac asimov was uh
lived in boston actually
um and i certainly could have met him
although by the time
i was sorted out and about and we had
quite a lot of mutual acquaintances
he tended to very much be a uh
just like everybody is with during this
pandemic somebody who just hung out
at home and wrote books um he wasn't
really an out and about kind of person
uh arthur c clarke um i certainly
exchanged letters with
um and uh uh i never met him
um i think i yeah i think we we
we talked once um but uh
uh he lived uh the last many years of
his life in sri lanka
which is not a place that i've been to
so i didn't have a chance to
uh to meet him in person um but he was
also very
uh in my interactions with him a very a
very positive person
um let's see
uh all kinds of interesting questions
here
let's go back a little bit um
uh okay here's a question from alan
water evaporates from the ocean and
moves up the water doesn't spread
uniformly over the sky
water vapor coalesces into discrete
clouds why is that
how come the humidity inside a cloud is
100 and right next to it is practically
zero
oh you're giving me interesting
difficult questions
well hmm
let's see how well i can do on that uh
the most relevant thing to say
yeah okay so first point is
when when water evaporates into the
atmosphere
the atmosphere is not completely uniform
there are always
air currents you know wind there are
always there's always convection where
hot air is rising cold air is falling
things like that it's not completely
uniform so there will be some parts in
which
there's uh you know the the um uh the
humid air is being pulled up higher
and will then cool off more and coming
down in some other place
there's a whole sort of dynamic process
of how things are moving around
now water and uh
the sort of interaction between water
and air is pretty complicated
um and uh the the properties of humid
air
are uh air okay so so air has certain
properties associated with being it's
a gas where for example if you heat air
up it expands
um if you and if you if you increase
pressure i mean there's a formula the
so-called gas laws
let's say for for an ideal gas
so an ideal gas is a gas where basically
there's a lot of space between molecules
and so in a first approximation what's
happening in for example the air which
is pretty close to an ideal gas
is the um uh
the molecules are just all they're doing
is just hitting each other like hard
billiard balls or something
they're not they don't have a force of
attraction between them that's important
all that's important is when they run
into each other they bounce off
and in a gas that has that form there's
a definite relationship between
pressure volume and temperature
so temperature of the gas is basically
the speed with which all these
all these molecules are bouncing around
the pressure of the gas
is kind of if you have a bunch of these
molecules in a box
how many of them are going to hit the
wall and bounce off because pressure
comes from a molecule bouncing off the
wall of the thing that you're trying to
that you're using to measure the
pressure
because when it bounces off it's like
like anything
where it where it hits the wall it
pushes the wall a bit
as it bounces off and that pushing that
force associated with it pushing the
wall
that's what leads to pressure and then
volume is just
how big is the box that you're putting
the gas into so the sort of the big lore
of the big gas law
discovered in the 1600s is pv
equals a constant times t uh pressure
times volume
equals a constant times absolute
temperature um
so that and that's what's true for an
ideal gas
a gas where all that happens is atoms
run into each other now uh you know
there are effects that don't happen in
an ideal gas for instance
uh well when in in a real gas
molecules uh it's not quite as easy to
pull molecules apart
as you might think the molecules have a
certain force of attraction between
them and so on and that leads to
important effects
and in the end what that leads to is the
possibility that the gas when you cool
it down enough
will turn into a liquid because if it
wasn't for the fact that there were
forces pulling these molecules together
the thing wouldn't condense into a
liquid okay
so what happens in in in the case of so
that's sort of the ideal gas law
when you mix um
air with water water vapor
the whole thing becomes vastly more
complicated and there's this
this thing called the phase diagram
which is a diagram that shows
uh uh the um uh usually
uh volume versus temperature
it's the most common phase diagram right
yes um and um
yeah this is about to get quite
complicated okay so
so among the complicated issues is
uh okay so for water
okay okay the okay so
water exists a liquid water also exists
as a gas
steam usually we're used to the idea
that as you increase the temperature of
water you boil your water
the water goes from being a liquid to
being a gas okay all straightforward
okay now it turns out that as you
change the temperature of
i'm sorry as you change the pressure of
water there comes a point in this phase
diagram
that's the so-called critical point of
water and at the critical point
the the line that sort of separates
liquid from gas
is no longer distinct so you you get
into this state
where where there's sort of a you can't
really tell
if it's a liquid or a gas and at that
point
there are all kinds of interesting
effects that happen so one thing that
happens is
that effectively you get sort of
droplets of all sizes
and that's kind of why you can't tell if
it's a liquid or a gas it's kind of got
liquid droplets and they're of all sizes
but also they're kind of all floating
around freely and so it's a gas
and there are all kinds of features of
of water at the critical point
um one thing is that uh there are well
there are features on all scales and
it's a it's a thing very much liked by
by theoretical physicists
because there's very elegant
mathematical theory of of scale and
variance
associated with it you change the scale
at which you're looking at it you know
you see droplets of different sizes
on any scale that you look at it that's
that's kind of what's happening in
clouds
and one of the reasons clouds are white
is because of
this phenomenon of um uh that it's water
at the critical point
now the the why am i why am i yakking on
about this
the reason is the formation of clouds
is associated with i mean it's a sort of
complicated relationship
between the properties of water vapor
interacting with air and what that means
as
as the cloud forms how that affects
things like the temperature pressure
volume
of of the air and um there's there's
quite a bit that is not
understood about the formation of clouds
i should should explain this
um and you know they're different kinds
of clouds so so for example a typical
thing that happens
in a cumulus cloud the fluffy clouds
that happen at like
10 000 feet or something fairly fairly
low or less than that
fairly low clouds um the the typical
thing that's happening there
um is uh that there are uh there is
convection
so there that means that there's hot air
rising cold air falling
and that is is bringing
the what does it do it brings the water
vapor up to the point
where it has cooled to the critical
point
and i think that's where the cloud forms
and the base of the cloud
is where the where where you reach the
critical point for water i think
um i i'm i'm um uh
and anyway so that that the you know
cumulus clouds are associated with this
sort of
updraft and downdraft and cirrus clouds
which happen at much higher altitudes
um are a um
somewhat different phenomenon now there
are gosh there are so many complicated
things here
and much that i don't know about um one
of the questions is
uh you know what causes a cloud to form
in a particular place
and so there's a whole discussion about
can you seed clouds
let's say you want it to rain you don't
want it to rain
you're putting on a giant sports event
you're putting on the olympics or
something
do you want to make sure it doesn't rain
over the olympics
can you can you you know can you fix the
atmosphere
so that that doesn't happen so there's
been a long discussion about what you
can do along those lines
and there's a long discussion about what
causes a cloud
or droplets in a cloud to form in a
particular place and there's a question
of whether the droplets require
kind of a seed to form whether there's a
grain of dust
whether there might be something that is
a leftover thing from
from a lightning storm or something or
leftover ion or something like this
that um uh that is the sort of the seed
that allows a droplet to form in a
particular place
and so one of the things that that has
been experimented with for more than 50
years now
is this thing called cloud seeding where
typically you have a plane
flyover and it drops out a bunch of i
think silver iodide i think is one of
the substances that that's used is that
right
um and uh the um
it doesn't sound right actually the
anyway there's some
something that you um that you use as a
as the kind of seeding agent where
you've got little tiny
uh tiny grains of this and the idea is
that those
form sort of nucleation centers for
water drops
that will then turn into a cloud now you
know once you have a cloud
there's a question of is it going to
rain and you know to what extent
does the does the the drops of water get
kind of
uh kept up in the cut aloft
by by for example updrafts of air and
things like this
and and what makes them sort of fall out
of the sky
and what tends to happen is in in a
cloud
the um the water drops uh first of all
they sort of gain in size by just
condensation of water
so so you know you've got a water drop
and if the cloud is
i guess cold enough you will get um
uh the there'll just be more water vapor
that goes from steam to liquid
water to make a bigger drop and at some
point the drop gets heavy enough
that it can no longer get sort of held
up by the updraft of air
um that's sort of keeping the cloud in
place
and so eventually the water drop will
fall out of the cloud and then it falls
as rain
but the thing that tends to happen is
that this there comes a critical size i
have a vague recollection it's 18
microns but i might be wrong
um where where the um uh where the drops
are big enough
that they no longer grow that they that
they start running into each other and
they start accumulating to the point so
so the eventual way that raindrops get
bigger is because the raindrops run into
each other
and you know lots of small drops turn
into a big drop so
first of all they form by condensation
just just water vapor
forming onto a single drop and then the
drops start running into each other
and eventually they get big enough and
they fall out of the cloud and they fall
as rain
um but uh uh that's some
and i know it certainly used to be the
case i i have not checked into this in
probably a couple of decades now it used
to be the case that it was very
mysterious
how you could go from kind of a
cloudless sky to having a cloud that was
actually raining in a matter of 15
minutes
that it wasn't very well understood how
you get sort of drops that are big
enough
to form in the cloud in order for that
to happen um
so a little bit a little bit complicated
and lots of things i actually don't know
um about uh about how that all works
it's it's always a big issue the the the
modeling of clouds is a complicated
issue when people try to make climate
models for example
um clouds are one of the one of the most
uncertain things
of of how will clouds be formed how many
clouds are there going to be
what effect will the clouds have clouds
are difficult
um and uh the the uh you know it's
partly because of this whole interaction
between the properties of air and the
properties of of
of water vapor and so on but clouds are
you know if if if you run into people
who say i know how to model the climate
i'm going to be able to figure out
everything about the future of climate
on the earth
you say you know it's a it's a good
question to ask to what extent you
managed
to capture what happens with clouds
because clouds are pretty important i
mean clouds
are not only do they affect the amount
of for example they reflect sunlight
back
they affect the amount of sunlight that
reaches the ground they affect
a lot of things about the circulation of
air and and so on
and uh they're they're complicated um
and and not uh completely well
understood
all right let's see um
there's a question here oh boy there's a
question here about the movie the matrix
you know the problem with these movies
is i see them once i think they're cool
i have a decent memory but i don't watch
them again
so i you know my sort of my my my memory
of these things probably decays over
time
i think that um uh the matrix
it's sort of um i found it um uh
kind of you know you can ask the
question if you're going to try and
explain a bunch of philosophical issues
you know what's the right packaging to
explain those issues it was a pretty
cool piece of packaging
to explain a bunch of those issues i
mean i kind of wonder in the in the
later matrix movies i
i i did wonder and i have never really
tried to find this out
whether the um uh the the people who um
who created the matrix knew about a
bunch of science that i've done because
there were definitely
aspects of particularly the the end of
the whole thing about the
source and the i forget sort of the
construction of the universe
that seemed awfully reminiscent of of um
uh
of things that um uh that i was figuring
out in the 1980s and so on but i don't
know whether there was a
causal connection between these things
um you know i think that the uh
um as kind of a metaphor well uh
as some um
you know i think this whole question of
um
uh sort of the relationship between sort
of the um
uh sort of the pure humans and us as
humans
and kind of the digital world and
i mean there's this whole issue of of uh
uh which i think the matrix to some
extent explores and i i must admit
my memory of exactly exactly what how it
exploded is
is a little bit fuzzy but um uh these
questions which means like
there's there's no need for a spoiler
alert because i don't remember enough of
the story to be able to spoil anything
but um uh the um um
uh this whole question about to what
extent
uh sort of humans do what they do with
free will
to what extent uh we are kind of
determined by the laws of physics for
example to do what we do
to what extent uh that is equivalent to
being determined by sort of
computational laws now you know in the
work that i've done
on sort of the relationship between
physics and computation and particularly
recently understanding a lot about
fundamental theory of physics
we're coming to realize that yes our
universe is
just sort of a giant computation that's
happening
the you know all the progress of time in
our universe
is just the execution of a big
computation and we are part of that
computation and all the things we do
are represented by part of that
computation now the thing that
you might say well that's really a very
depressing
outcome because it's like well all we're
doing is just being part of some
big completely determined computation
but the thing that kind of gets you out
of that box is this phenomenon i call
computational irreducibility
which is the fact that even though you
know the rules by which the thing
operates
if you want to know what's going to
happen after a billion steps of running
those rules
there's no way to know that other than
by basically running those billion steps
so in other words we don't get to jump
ahead and say
so the outcome of our lives is x
it's we still have to sort of live our
lives to understand that outcome or to
to know that outcome
and i think i think the matrix actually
did have some some sort of computational
irreducibility
thinking in it which which i'm kind of
guessing would have come from
from things i wrote in the 1980s but who
knows
um it's it's uh computational
irreducibility the idea of computational
irreducibility the idea
you can kind of know the rules for
something and not be able to sort of
predict
more efficiently than the thing itself
what's going to happen
that is an idea that that in a sense is
is really originated with things like
girdles theorem and mathematics in 1931
things like the halting problem in
turing machines and theory of
computation
without entering in 1936 but it was not
really understood as a thing that was
relevant to physics
until stuff i was doing in the 1980s and
so on it was always thought to be
something that was well
it's relevant to these computational
systems mathematical systems but that's
different
from what happens in in the real world
in the physical world and so on
so i think that that's some uh but
computational irreducibility is is a
very uh
uh you know if if there is one thing
that comes out of a lot of the sort of
fundamental thinking
that for example i've i've done about
how computation works
it's this phenomenon of computational
irreducibility it is
the ultimate limiter on science that is
you know when we when we do science we
think we're going to find out the
fundamental rules of a thing in the
universe
and then once we found out the
fundamental rules we might think
then we're done you know once we know
the rules for water vapor and this and
that and the other
then we can compute the what's going to
happen to the climate on the earth or
something
but it isn't true and it's it's in fact
one of the sort of fallacies of modern
science
the last probably three to five hundred
years people have kind of gotten this
idea what science is all about
is kind of drilling down and finding
these fundamental rules
and then we're done then we can figure
out everything science can give us all
the answers
what computational irreducibility shows
us is that that's not the case
from within science itself there are
fundamental limitations
the actual systems in science are ones
where there is no way to predict what
they're going to do other than by
essentially running them and seeing what
happens
and that's a consequence of this thing i
call the principle of computational
equivalence
but it's it's also that phenomenon is
this phenomenon of computational
irreducibility
so what is to me interesting in terms of
the sort of flow of history of science
is you know what we learned from
copernicus galileo newton and so on
was really this idea that uh you know we
could have these rules in science
these these theories of science which
would let us with
from this theory predict all the stuff
and we just kind of
have made this implicit assumption that
means we can predict everything
and it isn't true science from within
itself
has this built-in limitation that
prevents certain things from being
predictable
and requires that you basically just run
them and see what happens
and i think that's an important thing to
understand it's important not only in
understanding science
but also in understanding things about
sort of the what what it means for
artificial intelligence and
what it means for the predictability of
that and what it means for whether we
can say you know
can we tell that the ais are always
going to uh be good to us or something
well no because of computational
irreducibility
basically anyway long story
um there's a question here
about um uh
my thoughts on recent superconductor
breakthrough
yes i i noticed that i have not studied
it
i i don't know um and uh
i mean the yeah um
uh like let me explain what
superconductors are just for people
for people's interest um so
when you have a wire electrical wire
you try and push electricity through it
you have a voltage a voltage is kind of
the
the force that's pushing electrons
through the wire
the in a typical wire like a copper wire
or something
the electrons go through pretty well but
there's still some resistance to the
electrons going through that leads to
resistivity in the wire
that means that even though you're
pushing push and pushing with a certain
voltage to get these
electrons to go through the wire the
current the rate at which electrons go
through the wire
is is limited they're sort of pushed
back from the structure of the crystal
lattice
and what's happening is the electrons
are trying to go through
this uh this arrangement of copper atoms
and that roughly some of the electrons
are roughly sort of floating between
copper atoms and just being
able to get through but doesn't quite
work precisely like that
there is some resistance that exists to
the
to the flow of electrons through the
copper wire
so a thing that was discovered in the uh
first decade of the of the 20th century
was a phenomenon called
superconductivity if you cool
certain wires down far enough i think
lead and niobium were early ones
that were discovered if you cool the
wires down
to a low enough temperature that their
resistance the resistance to electrons
goes down and down down down down
and then suddenly at a critical
temperature the resistance to pushing
electrons through the wire goes to
zero not just small but actually zero
electrons you put a little a tiny a
tiniest voltage you can imagine
on the wire and electrons will just be
pushed through it
as fast as you want as as many as you
want
um so that's the phenomenon of
superconductivity
and once you have a superconducting wire
you can uh you can get a current to flow
through that superconducting wire
uh you can get lots of current to flow
through
and there's no there's no resistance why
is resistance important so
let's say you're trying to uh you've got
an electrical power
electric power station and it's
generating lots of lots of electricity
and you want to transfer that
electricity to some place that's a
thousand miles away
well you put it through a wire but
there's a resistance to getting that
that electricity through the wire and
that resistance to
when you what what actually happens is
that the the the sort of the force you
try and push things through
with doesn't succeed in getting all the
electricity through
um instead some of that force is just
turning into heat
it's not successfully pushing electrons
through it's just turning into heat
and so when you see electrical wires
turns out the higher the voltage
that you're using the less uh
compared to the amount of current you're
getting through the the less heat you
produce
um but um it's it's still the case that
you can't get rid of the heat that
you're producing
unless the wire is superconducting if
the wire is superconducting
um then the resistance to pushing the
electrons through zero no heat is
generated
by getting the electrons to go through
the wire now in
the um there's a little bit of a catch
which is that superconductors typically
if you try and put too much current
through them the current produces a
magnetic field
and the magnetic field actually breaks
down the superconductivity so
superconductors usually have both the
critical temperature if you heat them up
too much
they stop being superconductors and a
critical magnetic field
so basically if you put too much current
through the superconductor it stops
being a superconductor anymore
um it's uh um
uh okay the question from flying here if
the resistance goes to zero with the
electron start accelerating without
bound
um it doesn't actually accelerate
without bound i'm a little bit cheating
and describing
the um uh how this works
the um the fuller story
oh boy can i get to this fuller story
the fuller story has to do with the
so-called conduction bands
of um it's a story of quantum mechanics
and essentially it isn't really right to
think about
individual electrons being pushed
through the wire what's really true
is that there's this kind of delocalized
electron
field that exists in the wire and
when you're when you're putting a a
voltage you're
you're sort of uh you're sort of
distorting that that
electron field and so it's not really a
question of just
saying you know individual electron go
faster faster faster
um electrons go through wires at a at a
fraction maybe a tenth of the speed of
light
usually um in some in some sense of
measuring that you can you can sort of
send a signal through a wire at a
certain speed
um now anyway about superconductors
so for quite a long time nobody
understood
how you could get down to uh
you could get sort of zero resistivity
for
um for electrons going through a wire
um what was realized
is that actually the phenomenon of
superconductivity is
basically the same phenomenon as the
phenomenon that causes lasers to work
and and the way lasers work is
essentially you've got
a bunch of photons and you arrange it so
that
kind of all the photons in the laser
want to do the same thing
they all kind of want to be exactly
lined up
exactly in phase so that their uh
light waves are all lined up and they
won't be going in exactly the same
direction
you know making a laser beam and and
that that phenomenon of things wanting
to sort of all be in the same state
is a phenomenon of quantum mechanics
associated with
uh so-called bosons uh certain uh
particles uh and this is gets a little
complicated but particles that have
integer spin um of which uh
photons are an example they have spin
one um
uh like to get in the same state if you
put lots of photons together
they'll want to do the same thing
electrons which have spinner half
work quite differently if you try and
push lots of electrons into the same
state
they exclude each other there's this
thing called the exclusion principle
and that's actually why matter is stable
is because of that exclusion principle
because if there weren't electrons and
other
a half particles and so on matter will
just collapse
it's it's the fact that there's this
sort of exclusion of things
that prevents these electrons from all
sort of occupying the same space and so
on
that causes matter to to be stable but
anyway so
so electricity is made of electrons so
there's a question of can you get
something like the laser case where
where in the laser case
these are these photons are all sort of
ganging up together
and so they they kind of have if there
was a question of resistance
and doesn't work quite the same way for
light it would be like they're all
in it together and they're all able to
sort of push through together
and and overcome that that sort of
resistance
um i think that the um
uh the question of um uh what
um uh so okay how does that work for for
electrons which like to exclude things
like to not be in the same state
was discovered in the 1950s or 60s i
think
what actually happens in superconductors
is the thing the formation of these
things called cooper pairs
which are places where pairs of
electrons have
paired up and so the electron has spin a
half but these pairs
have for example spin zero um because
it's like a
half minus a half gives you zero um and
it's these pairs of electrons
that allow you to get superconductivity
now there's a question of okay
can we make a superconductor that the
big question is can we make a
superconductor that works at
room temperature most superconductors
work only a few degrees above absolute
zero at temperatures of liquid helium
and things like this
um so they're very you know they only
work in very very cold temperatures
can we get a superconductor that will
work at something like room temperature
um so that we could use it in practical
kinds of things that we're
we're doing in in typical everyday
settings
and that's been a big adventure to try
and find high-temperature
superconductors
there was a about 30 years ago people
found
a set of materials that have very very
exotic materials
with elements like lanthanum in them and
so on uh whole sort of weird
weird materials that uh are high
temperature superconductors but by high
temperature
it means uh you know maybe 100 degrees
above absolute zero
not uh reaching kind of room temperature
which is uh
300 degrees above absolute zero so
the thing that um uh um
there's been this kind of big hunt on
for can one find a material
that will make a high-temperature
superconductor the theory of how
even the high temperature and quotes
high temperature superconductors that
exist today
work is really quite incomplete um so
there's this sort of this question
of is there a way to find a material
which
by some weird feature of the way that it
interacts with electrons and the way
that
this and that happens manages to make a
superconductor at room temperature
and and uh there's been some recent
progress which i really have not studied
in the last couple weeks
on this um and uh uh
you know this is a challenge if it is
successful
it will lead to all kinds of cool things
i mean you know the magnets that exist
today
back in the day most people just had
iron magnets
but in the last probably 20 30 years
so-called rare earth magnets made with
uh with elements like gadolinium and so
on
have become pretty common and rare earth
magnets
are are much stronger than ordinary you
know usually the the magnetic
elements are iron cobalt nickel um
but there are other elements that are
sort of below them on the periodic table
like gadolinium
um i think sumerian maybe there's
another one but gadolinium is the most
common one that's
used for this um that have kind of much
stronger magnetism
and so a lot of magnets that you'll find
a lot of
modern sort of consumer electronics
devices are rare earth magnets galvanium
magnets and things like that
and uh if we had superconductors at room
temperature
we would have all kinds of interesting
uh oh
i should say that as soon as you have a
superconductor you can kind of make this
loop of wire and when you have a loop of
wire with the current going around it
that makes a magnetic field
so you can you can use this to make
magnets you can use it to transmit
electricity easily
you can use it for all kinds of purposes
um and you know once you have a
superconductor and you have a current
going round as a superconductor
it will go around for months at a time
it it really doesn't there really is no
resistance to motion
all right we should wrap up quite quite
soon here
ah dvl is saying uh
it's their birthday happy birthday to
i can't read your your um uh uh
your handle here but but uh dvl
something
um uh
i'm um yeah
it's always um
yeah well happy birthday anyway
um let's see that
maybe one more question here
by as a question um
ah the the login was devil or angel okay
that's interesting well
happy birthday devil or angel
um
that's an interesting question all right
i'm going to do maybe two more here
it's a question from cambridge um why
doesn't every single
thought episode last forever why does
thought disappear
after it arises why does
why does our memory for example decay
when we
when we think about something why are we
not kind of
why is that not sort of permanently
etched in our brains so to speak
why does it decay away i mean we don't
know completely how
so so in a first approximation our
brains are working
with electrical impulses in our neurons
and once an electrical signal
when when a neuron has transmitted an
electrical signal to another neuron
then it's gone so to speak that that
electrical signal is
is then transmitted onto the next neuron
and it's
it's disappeared but the question is uh
you know is there a memory
of what that signal was
um and the answer is uh well
probably not that we can access but some
signals for whatever reason uh leads to
a sort of permanent memory and and there
are
various detailed theories about how this
happens and it's becoming clear that
that some of what happens in artificial
neural nets is actually closer
to the way it works in real brains than
we thought but in a first approximation
the um uh there are you know memories
are formed
in the synapses and the connections
between neurons it seems
and uh there are uh things that are uh
usually there's a sort of short-term
memory that arises from
from particular proteins being produced
um
in those uh in those synapses i think
the longer term memories
end up being actual pores actual
channels that exist in the neurons
uh calcium channels things like that
it's almost like a little tiny tiny
piece of rock
that is being being sort of uh uh
created
in the the that uh is opening up or not
or not opening up the ability
of um of these uh connections between
neurons to exist
um so uh there's sort of the and there's
then the question of
if we have a memory and we've had a
memory for 10 years
how does that memory go away how does
that memory
get erased we don't really know the
answer to that
one possibility is it's kind of like
computer memory we just use that piece
of memory again
that neuron sorry that neuron which was
the original neuron that was used to
learn some word in french when you were
a kid
is now being reused to be uh
the thing that you are uh
that is remembering something about some
movie you just saw that's a possibility
that it's
just being reused that our brains just
don't have enough space to store
everything that they need to store and
that we're just going to reuse
pieces of storage space so to speak
that's a possibility
another possibility is that gradually
chemical processes degrade
whatever it is that that maintains
memory in a particular neuron
another possibility is the neuron just
dies um we know that
um uh from from the
when uh when one's born there is a
certain rate at which neurons die it
used to be thought that
that you're kind of you're born with all
the neurons you're ever going to get
and neurons just die and no new neurons
are born
it became clear about 20 years ago now
that no actually
new neurons can be created in in human
brains in adult brains for example
so it's it's sort of not all over it's
not all downhill from the time you're
born
you can get new neurons now presumably a
new neuron
once it exists doesn't remember anything
it doesn't know anything
if an old neuron that remembered
something dies then you presumably lose
those memories
um although it's a slightly more
complicated story because all these
neurons are connected to all these other
neurons
and it's the it's the sort of whole
network of connections that presumably
is responsible for storing the memories
that we have
let's see one one last question here i
think um
it's a question for from anonymous how
do you get your staff to get so much
done
especially so much hard stuff um
well look the first thing about getting
hard stuff done
is you have to believe it's possible and
you know if there's nobody involved who
believes it's possible it's not going to
happen
so at some point you have to if you're
leading a group of people
it's kind of like look this is a thing
it's worth doing
and it's possible even though it may
seem very very hard
even though it's like no we can't do
this it's way too difficult
way too little time way too hard you
know people have been trying to do that
for a long time
can't be done etc etc etc i think the
first thing is
so the zeroth thing is you have to
believe it yourself
because if you don't believe it's
possible yourself it's going to be very
hard to communicate to other people
yes this is possible we can really do
this i think that the another
feature of of working with other people
and i i've had the the good fortune i
suppose to
to work with lots of very talented
people over the course of many decades
now
um you know it's it's i i would say that
there
are uh sort of a you know finding
talented people and then finding
talented people
who are a fit with your style of doing
things
i mean i i know that um there are lots
of talented people where i'd say
that's a fantastic person they're going
to do fantastic things
but they'll go crazy working at our
company and we'll go crazy with them
and um it's uh you know it's it's
something where
there's a certain sort of fit that's
needed uh to work with people now i
think one of the things that's really
nice about
our company for example is we have a
very great diversity of
types of people and personalities and so
on and i i guess i pride myself i don't
know really how
how how much i should pride myself on
this but i i think i probably i pride
myself
on being able to work with lots of
different kinds of personalities
and being able to uh to help people sort
of do the best work they can
um you know with a with a whole
diversity of a very
optimistic personalities very
pessimistic personalities
very uh sort of uh people who
sort of do everything they're told
people who never do what they're told
people who you know just a range of
different kinds of um
kinds of personalities and i think the
the trick really is
in doing a project it's like you've got
a project you imagine this project
has got to be done now you've got a pool
of people it's like how do you solve the
puzzle
of how do these different people fit
into the project that you're trying to
do
and i think that's a thing that is uh
it's a it's an interesting problem it's
kind of the
the the i see it as being sort of a core
problem managing people and projects and
so on
is is to do that sort of matching and
it's not the case you say i've got this
project
now just you know get me a person who
fits in this in this slot
that's that's usually not the the thing
that's going to work it's usually
there's this person and they're you know
a puzzle piece for a certain shape
and there's this project and it has a
sort of puzzle piece of a certain shape
how do you fit these things together and
sometimes you redefine the project a
little bit
sometimes you you have to sort of
uh have the person understand how they
can fit into this thing
that they originally thought oh i don't
do things like that well actually here's
the way you think about
it so that you realize you can do things
like that um i think those are
uh those are those are some types of
things i think also you know
as in leading projects and leading
difficult projects
you kind of have to be able to roll up
your sleeves and do a lot of the the
work
uh you know at least be in a position to
do the work yourself
i mean it's it's a big trade-off for me
for example you know i have the sort of
the
the the misfortune the good fortune and
the misfortune
of having by this point a lot of
experience of doing lots of kinds of
projects
and it's it's a question of you know to
what extent should i just
do it myself and to what extent should i
delegate it to other people to do
um and you know that's a complicated
trade-off because if it's something
where
i can do it pretty deterministically in
30 minutes
and if i if i hand it off to somebody
else to do it might take them a week
and there might be a chance of you know
30 chance that they don't manage to do
it at all
should i spend the 30 minutes to do it
or should i
um should i have that risk and the and
the much longer time of somebody else
doing it
that's a complicated trade-off because
you can't do everything yourself the
great thing about working with people is
that
it dramatically expands the range and
the size and so on and projects that you
can do
just because it's just much more much
more bandwidth to to get things done
but on the other hand there's this
question of if you can do something more
efficiently
you know when should you do it yourself
versus when should you delegate to other
people
it's a complicated thing and i i i spend
a lot of effort trying to get that right
i don't always get it right
um but that's one of the challenging
things i think it's also
important for me at least is most things
that i can delegate
to other people well are things that in
principle i could do myself
i might not be able to do it as well as
the person i delegate it to
but at least i could do it it's not
something where it's like i don't
understand this at all
i couldn't possibly do it um and uh
you know i think that's a that's an
important thing i found that things
where
where i'm just like oh go do this i
don't really understand how it could
possibly be done
that doesn't usually end well it's if i
understand the
thing that has to be done but the person
i'm giving it to might be better at
doing it than i am
um then that's uh uh you know that's a
that's a reasonable handoff but you know
it's it's a um
uh it's it's always a uh i mean my
my staff for better or worse are always
telling me
who are mostly much younger than me at
this point you know i when i was younger
i always used to be working with people
who are older than me
and and sometimes that that caused all
kinds of problems
and it was i realized this is one of
these problems that
that for better or worse solves itself
with time um and now i mostly work with
people just demographically who are
who are younger than me but um uh
they're they're often telling me that i
i have a lot of energy
and um i i've been i suppose i'm
fortunate that still at my
sort of ancient age i still have enough
energy to sort of tenaciously do
projects for
for long periods of time and so on and i
think that
it's it's some sort of the the uh the
the the projection of of energy and
tenacity about doing projects is really
important
to get people to you know to do projects
i mean
we just did a project that just sort of
more or less ended this last monday
which was a project to investigate um
uh these things called combinators which
i'm not going to describe in great
detail here but but
um that was sort of a very early um
perhaps the earliest kind of um
uh uh invention of the the sort of the
main idea of computation
and they were originated by a talk that
was given
on december 7th 1920. and so we were i
was very keen i'd had this in my in my
calendar for like years
to um to sort of celebrate that that
centenary
um and so we were we were really keen to
i was really keen
to sort of figure out a bunch of things
technically about combinators
figure out a bunch of things about the
history of how they came to be invented
um and we had a very definite deadline
which was monday of this week
um where we did a sort of event about
these things um
and uh that was a that was a bit of a
struggle because that was a
was a project where we really had no
sense of scope
it wasn't clear how much could be
discovered about combinators wasn't
clear how difficult the history was how
much could be discovered in the history
and so on and we started oh i know
probably six weeks ago or something now
working on this and it became clear that
there was a lot to do i mean a lot a lot
to do
and in the end i i ended up writing
probably
350 pages or something of material about
combinators in their history um and that
all had to be finished by monday morning
and i will say that that was uh even for
me that was and i i tend to do difficult
projects and i tend to do them in
in sort of extreme um uh um
uh perhaps extreme ways that was for me
a little bit on the
on the uh on the extreme end of extreme
project so to speak just in terms of
you know i had originally thought oh
this is going to be a you know a short
thing of a few tens of pages and so on
not a 350 page
monstrosity full of full of a bunch of
new research
both on the technical side and the
historical side but it was a lot of fun
um and uh uh it's um
i'm glad i'm glad i had a chance to do
it and i'm also glad in a sense there
was a deadline for it because
uh uh that that has caused it to get
done
uh it's got a little bit of trailing
stuff that has to happen actually i need
to get going now because
we have another intense project which is
that we are about to release the new
version of wolfram language
and it's my job to uh uh to write
a sort of essay about it and i just
started that earlier today
and i have an intense next few days um
putting together
um all the aspects of that and i think i
better go back to um
uh to working on that now but um anyway
nice to be with you guys for a little
while um and
um uh look forward to um
going on um uh
next week see you then